hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book 1 chapter
6 of his Nicomachean ethics Aristotle is
engaging in some very interesting and
important criticisms of Plato and the
plateless and remember he's only one
generation removed from Plato himself
with whom he studied and is an
interlocutor with the contemporary plate
inist
who are a school literally right across
town from him and so he is departing
considerably from the Platonic
understanding of good and good and in a
certain respect and that way from their
efforts that's also worth pointing out
to a little side note that that he makes
he says that you know we have a
friendship with the author of the
authors of the theory of ideas but it
perhaps it would appear desirable and
obligatory especially for a philosopher
to sacrifice even ones closest personal
ties this friendship in favor of truth
he thinks that there's something
fundamentally off about the Platonic
doctrine of the good so what is he
trying about there
got a portion of that up here the
Platonic inception but this holds not
just for the good but for all sorts of
other things not every single thing but
but all sorts of things they assume that
there is a form or idea the express its
you know sometimes using one in words
sometimes another something the thing
itself even with all of the things of
that class participate so you know
there's a form for example human being
and I would be just a copy of that form
you would be another copy of that form
we're not the reality itself the reality
is the form in which we somehow
participate were modeled after
participation is a complex thing as well
and we're not going to get too deep into
that Aristotle says that the originators
of this theory postulated ideas of
groups of things and which they posited
an order of priority and posterior and
that means that the thing the thing that
we look at the existing thing like book
is in certain respects later or pus
posterior or dependent upon the
archetype the ideal book so Aristotle is
going to point out a number of problems
with this theory as applied to the good
I put little you know sort of blurbs
about them here you'd want to actually
go to the text and look at that each of
them to see the full discussion so the
first thing that he says is he brings up
this notion of categories and this is
this is a something I'm doing another
video about that you can take a look at
where we'll go into a little bit more
discussion about it a category it is a
fundamental way of saying something
about something so for example when
you're talking about the nature of the
thing itself that is the category of
what we call substance so to say you
know man is a rational animal or human
being is rash
hungry about putting off repulses we
translate it either way very your
signifying the the substance you say
something about it as that kind of
substance other categories would include
saying tall right that is a quality or
actually it's not even quality that's a
quantity than I have that's a different
category that's that's in what the
aerosol calls the problem accidents
there's a lot involved there I don't
want to get to deeper than that
what's the upshot of this well since the
good is spoken of in many different ways
that makes it seem unlikely that there
could be one single overarching idea of
good that thereby encompasses all of the
things that we call good if there were
only one single thing we wouldn't expect
that all these different categories all
these different modes of talking about
goodness if it seems hard to you know
bring them all together under one
concept he also says this is following
up on this that things that are under a
single idea or form should be under a
single discipline or if you like science
or art you know just make sure you
understand science to be something
different than the what we nowadays call
science which is in certain ways a bit
more restricted and also a bit more
expansive what doesn't include
everything that that plane over aerosol
would call the sciences but one is short
of this is that Aristotle is saying if
there really was one single idea of good
there should be only one discipline they
have treats of it because it could
encompass everything that falls under
that idea instead what do we find out he
says that there are a number of Sciences
for example if we think about you know
the good of opportunity you know in war
opportunity comes
the science of strategy in disease under
that of medicine that do amount in diet
that's a good thing you know the Metreon
comes under medicine and bodily exercise
under gymnastics and we could expand
this more and more and more so the good
is dealt with by multiple you know
disciplines or arts or sciences and
therefore it's not one single unified
thing with a plate of the same then he
brings up a metaphysical objection one
that also has to do with knowledge the
problem of the third man he doesn't
bring it up as as under that name that's
that's something that later on people
will ascribe to it this is a famous
argument against plato's forms and the
way that it runs is like this you say
okay here's a man here is a human being
now there's some sort of you know idea
out there floating around or maybe in a
different world or who knows where human
being and I in some way participated I'm
going to copy I have a copy of that idea
you know but however we conceive of that
now how do we know that I am actually a
copy of that how do we relate me to that
archetype we have to do so with what is
common to both of us but wait a second
that thing is supposed to be what is
common to all human beings and so now
there is a third there the third man
comes in a third perhaps form or
something like that that is the
archetype for both the archetype and
myself and if we can do it once like
that then we can still ask another
question we'll go on to infinity and the
Greeks did not like infinity split on
those abandoned yeah this would be a bad
idea anyway Arizona's not exactly saying
precisely that instead what do you say
in terms of ideal man and man here he
says insofar as both are human being
there's no difference if so no more will
there be any difference between the
ideal good and
good insofar as they're good if they you
know if they both have the same
definition then look either the
definition of the third thing in which
we'd better be looking at that
definition rather than thinking about an
idea order they're in effect the same if
they have the same definition that in
that respect they're the same so the
form of the good or the idea of good and
good insofar as they are both good are
really the same thing and they also
consider is another issue Plato thought
and a lot of people to think that those
ideals are better in certain way because
they're eternal and they're not time
bound or spaced Bob and Aristotle says
why will they ideal good be any more
good because it's eternal it's not as if
a white thing that lasts a long time is
any whiter than a thing that is only
white for a day this is also by the way
a line of reasoning that Aristotle is
not entirely consistent with throughout
the rest of his works but it is an
interesting way to attack I think now he
considers a possible objection that the
plaintiffs might make here he's being
very charitable to them he's saying look
they might try to respond to me by
saying this isn't supposed to sigh diya
of the good isn't supposed to deal with
all goods let's make a distinction
between things that are good in
themselves are desired for their own
sakes or they're pursued for their own
sakes things that we recognize as
intrinsic wins and then all those other
useful goods over there right so would
would be examples of intrinsic goods
Aristotle talks for example about wisdom
you know that's something that people do
pursue for its own sake what else does
he talk about pleasure pleasure is
something that people do seek for its
own sake at least certain pleasures
honors you know you couldn't suppose
seek honors in order to gain something
out of it but many people do in fact
seek honor because they see
as an intrinsic good the virtues now
what would be you know other things
well the useful goods that we're going
to put over on the side the problem is
Aristotle points up is that these goods
are not only multiple which wouldn't be
a bit that bigger problems they could
all be brought under one common idea but
they have different irreducible accounts
or definitions or however you want to
translate lowboy we have different
conceptions of them pleasure is not the
same thing and it's not understood in
the same way and as is virtue which is
not reducible to wisdom and neither none
of these are reducible to honor these
are distinct they are need goods but
they are not dealt with according to the
same conception although he studies the
work good of them so they're not
following under one platonic conception
of the good one of the more interesting
objections that Aristotle will make
towards the end of this discussion he
has to do with you might say whether
there are adopters of this this idea and
Plato had suggested that it's important
to think about these ideal forms because
they are the pattern or the archetype
for the creative things that we have if
we want to create other things like
let's say we want to create justice in a
human being it will be to our benefit to
look to the archetype of justice rather
than to individual instances of justice
because the archetype is the the clear
pattern or model which then we can
employ as sort of like a blueprint now
your style points out a real interesting
problem with this in asking well if it's
so useful then why don't we see people
in the Arts and Sciences talking a lot
more about the
good why don't the disciplines actually
discuss it and and look to it so he says
here we go these are all a met some good
and seek to make up their deficiencies
but they don't trouble about a knowledge
of the ideal good it's improbable that
all the professors of the arts and
sciences should not know it or even seek
to discover it I suppose the plainest
could say well you know this is indeed a
discovery on Plato's part it's only been
a generation let's see if it will sink
yeah I think in our time we could
probably say this has become a stronger
argument on Aristotle's part he also
goes on and he says why don't they
discuss it I'll give you a reason it's
really hard to see how he gives you the
example of a carpenter for example or a
physician he says it's not easy to see
how knowing that the same ideal good the
form of the good will help a weaver or
carpenter in the practice of his craft
or how anyone will be a better physician
or general for having contemplated this
idea that doesn't mean that we shouldn't
study ethics or think about the nature
of the good but Aristotle it is in
essence I'm saying the Platonic way of
approaching this doesn't seem to be
particularly helpful or useful in doing
ethics or in thinking about other fields
in which the good is motivating people